welcome to this video against crypto
chess crypto chess I never played him is
this the time for as English variation
maybe it is come on check the delete the
delayed Samish ok going for a quick
check on my pawn em way is he going to
be seven on what exactly I'm going to
just develop him 45 I guess I don't know
i should think about it for a moment
because his desk just dashing out stuff
and not really looking at the position
so there might be ways to punish him for
all that ok what defy this the normal
move Bishop g5 also comes into
consideration its various ways now to to
sacrifice your form but ok let's do D 5
take stakes he has to take on d3 first I
guess okay c4 is also a lipid I'm
breaking through a bit here with the
center this is why I was a bit skeptical
about just playing this like instantly
this is not a theoretical position and
there are some points to that for what I
mean I have a center it's not like it's
completely completely harmless it's not
sure what you should do I mean what is
what the most precise way is maybe he
can take place afore to prevent me from
playing see for supporting the center
this might be might be a good see for
now probably not but see for here this
is so this is a possibility okay if I go
see for now there is some there is a
queen to a six but it's not clear that
this really helps them look q1 and ce4
looks right in general now let's do that
very unclear stuff to take with the pond
23 or somewhere else young c3 or we're
not clear probably here
now is a critical moment e 6 or not e 6
or not
he's six you can maybe take with the
deep on Queen g7 long castles looks
really insane but maybe possible okay i
still play that it's kind of logical I
mean Bishop e3 is not bad for wine at
all but yeah I don't know maybe I should
have played this just Bishop e3 trying
to prove that his knights are really in
bad shape but i wonder if i should
should play d 7 okay
they're 90 force what he wants to play
quickly
yeah I should have played we should be
3n just just just laid it a bit in a bit
simpler way this is just totally chaotic
even if it is better for white which I'm
not sure it is it is total chaos in
which basically anything can happen okay
take take their own g-form there's
always this stuff on the G file
95 is also moved one lamb I can have a
hard time to him to assess this him also
has an ID be three all the time whoopee
one night be three and yeah hard hard to
calculate want to get in d 7 this idea
and cover against Ruby 6
this made on g2 sa it's really annoying
with to no end maybe f3 somewhat to help
to help against the made on g2 not
really sure maybe you can just take this
6cm not quite positive what I'm what I'm
playing against that maybe 9 f 7 I'm
just grabbing yeah that's possible no
doubt now I can play night see for at
least theoretically speaking not sure if
maybe my morning maybe he's got Luke g5
then Wow rook t5 I have 96 I think I but
at the end he stood has extra material
there he can take on daehan g5 with with
the G rogue he still had it has a
totally winning position after that I
thought rook takes Queen takes rook
takes 96 check but at the end he has two
nights and upon answer look so yeah it's
not seeing it okay he could have just
taken maybe this is also good don't know
95 back or what
getting the bishop to g3 would be would
be nice I can take g3 now yeah anyway
anyway 20 seconds yeah he will promote
them check check check yeah come on
white reasons yeah I shouldn't I really
shouldn't have taken on g7 or this e 6
business I think he's just he's just
worse if I don't do that going for this
complications was wrong so sometimes try
too hard to punish bad player and
sometimes should just play simple chest
and by the way why is this I mean is
there anything else maybe Bishop g5 is
very strong this is this is winning
almost why exactly is it winning night
see form okay well this is just not
looking good right yeah this is just
threatening this I see I see okay but
I'm interested in the position after
this as well because this is the simple
way to play and have thought it also
should be quite good I queen bee three
yeah okay this is this might might be
okay this might be okay i was thinking i
get in lucca p1 all the time and here
now he as he is okay I mean I have no
problem with the porn down but okay I
seem so and this this really is just a
complete
unclear mess and probably it is more
more good for for black than it is and
then it is for me it's possible that in
all those complications I had had an
advantage but it's just mostly mostly a
crapshoot take stakes and now f3 is just
Emma just blunders I didn't see that on
I don't know what what he overlooked but
this is just this just wins of course
but I hey I was I was glad to see this
idea yeah but this is of course just
just lost at the end with the pawn so
where he made this one and Jim knigu to
do now yeah this is just play like like
Latium it's a yo I don't know him
complete completely crazy like this now
yeah and perpetuum yeah well I don't
know the the clearest way to tackle this
opening play was around here knigu 5 was
also very good okay yeah I mean I really
don't believe in that yeah I'm playing
12 moves in 15 seconds in a position
that you don't know and it's clear that
this is no theoretical position at all
so okay but it was really good but I
have to go Bishop g5 is just much
stronger yeah yeah the thing is that
this is not working at all I mean he
just resins and this means he he has a
hard time to come up with anything else
than night c4 I mean this is what the
computer suggests but this is terrible
and simply terrible for black
ritee to our age form it is still murky
definitely okay well thanks for watching